جدل واسع في الاردن اثرته تصريحات لقاضي
القضاه الشيخ عبد الحافظ الربطه خلال
مؤتمر صحفي كان يتكلم خلاله عن نسب وحلات
الزواج في المملكه
هيئه تعتقد اجتماع من اجل دراسته احنا
مثلا اليوم عرض علي نائب اتصل بيقول انه
في وحده عمرها 16 سنه ونصف وبدنا تحاول
انك تزوج قلت احنا في عندنا طرق قانونيه
بدنا نمشي فيها ضمن التعليمات وقديش عمر
الزوج قال الزوج عمره 35 سنه كتلات
تراجعنا ولا شيء اذا كان هناك فارغ فوق 18
15 سنه هذا الفارق احنا
نرفض انه نزوجه
لاقل من 18 اذا بلغت فوق ال18 سنه هي حره
تتزوج او لا تتزوج لكن احنا مسؤولين عنها
بولايتنا بان لا نزوجها ثم ننظر كذلك اذا
جاؤوا من خلال هل هي على مقاعد الدرس هل
هي حالتها الاجتماعيه ولا نقبل واسطات جاء
واحد علينا نائب ما بدناش نسمي اسمه بده
ياخذ واحده عمرها 15 سنه وهي راضيين وكلهم
راضيين ويمكن يكونوا مبسوطين انهم فازوا
بنائب ما في اقل من 18 سنه لو مين ما كنت
تزعل ترضى انت حر هذه البنت بنتنا جميعا
قاد القضاه كما شاهدنا سويا تكلم عن رغبه
نائب لم يكشف عن هويته في الزواج من فتاه
قاصر تبلغ من العمر 15 عاما وعن محاوله
نائب اخر الوساطه لتزويج فتاه اخرى عمرها
16 عاما ونصف وقال انه في كلتال حالتين تم
رفض الامر من قبل دائره القضاء بسبب عدم
اتمام الفتاتين سن الثامنه عشره والسن
الزواج القانوني في الاردن هذا التصريح
اثار غضبا وجدلا واسعين في الاردن بسبب
زواج القاصرات وكيف يمكن ان يقبل نواب في
البرلمان على مثل هذا الامر المرفوض
قانونيا واخلاقيا بعد هذا الغضب نشرت
وسائل اعلام اردنيه نقلا عن مصدر مطلع في
دائره القاضي القضاه لان النائب الذي تحدث
عنه قاضي القضاه نائب سابق والقصه قديمه
لا علاقه لها بمجلس النواب الحالي لكن رغم
ذلك فالغضب لم يهدا ووصل لقبه مجلس
حيث ارسل النائب زياد العتوم خطابا الى
قاضي القضاه يطالبه فيها بالاعتذار رسميا
من كل نواب ويتهمه بالاساءه للسلطه
التشريعيه وقال ان المقطع ازعجه هو
وزملائه وسال عقاد القضاه
الاستهداف النواب فقط وتحدث عن الحادثتين
اللتين ذكرهما رغم ان قصصا كهذه كثيره
وتعرض عليه يوميا
[موسيقى]